este es tal anal el cerebro del llamado
Tim George un grupo con sede en Israel
liderado por este ex oficial de las
fuerzas especiales israelíes y cuyo
seudónimo George ha dado el nombre al
grupo que ofrece a sus clientes campañas
de influencia adelantadas a través de
decenas de miles de cuentas falsas en
las redes sociales sus actividades
fueron expuestas por un informe de la
organización forbidden Stories en el que
participaron varios medios se trata de
una empresa que siembra el caos en
diferentes lugares del planeta lo hace
utilizando una serie de herramientas
primero falsifica cuentas digitales
luego también puede falsificar
documentos o incluso plantar información
ficticia en cuentas digitales haciéndose
pasar por intermediarios de clientes
potenciales los periodistas consiguieron
citas con equipos del Team George estos
presumieron haber trabajado en más de 30
elecciones presidenciales en todo el
mundo principalmente en África y
detallaron algunas de sus operaciones
tanto por cuenta de Estados como de
actores privados la empresa pública
historias inventadas que hace creer a la
mayoría de la gente que les han robado
elecciones en algunos países de África
como en Kenia por ejemplo al hacerlo
crea un clima de desestabilización pieza
central
que controla un ejército de cuentas
falsas en las grandes redes sociales
para diseminar sus campañas de
desinformación sus miembros dijeron a
los periodistas que incluso pueden
buscar información sobre opositores
políticos para practicar diversas formas
de chantaje